if i told you i know how
it all ends right once you know how it
all ends that
that the only use of time is how do i
buy more bitcoin
uh i gotta talk bitcoin real quick so i
am a bitcoin investor
i don't even know what a bitcoin is
it hurts to spend that much money in one
shot i've never done anything like this
in my whole life
and um well it's gonna be very
interesting to see the results
[Music]
bitcoin what is it how does it work
should you invest in it
this video is sponsored by our friends
bitcoin cannot be stopped
bitcoin is going to a hundred thousand
dollars and why bitcoin in the long term
is going to be worth more than one
million dollars per
coin but take all your money by bitcoin
then take all your time figure out how
to borrow more money to buy more bitcoin
then take all your time and figure out
what you can sell to buy bitcoin
and if you absolutely love the thing
that you're that you don't want to sell
it
go mortgage your house and buy bitcoin
with it
[Music]
available funds 136 pound
that's what i have in my bank i told you
i spent it all so i bought it all time
highs which was not smart you know i
should have bought
by the depth always by the depth never
get caught up in fomo you know just wait
a day
let me let me explain something to you
right now okay here's a 10
bill this is garbage this is garbage
you're people in south africa you have
your rand right that's going to zero
that's going to zero this is going to
zero two euros are going to zero the
ends going to zero
the chinese currency is going to zero
it's all going to zero against bitcoin
if you don't understand that yet you're
going to be impoverished you're going to
be on the street you're going to be
begging you're going to be out of
business you're going to be toast max do
you know that it's a criminal offense
to tear up do you know that with the
bitcoin i have i can buy any
freaking senator or congressman i want i
make the laws
he who has the bitcoin makes the laws
ran we're not going to just sit around a
little
god damn god is going to tell us what to
do we've got the capital
we make the laws we've got the bitcoin
we don't
we got it they don't you understand
[Music]
you